i just want to bring you some breaking
news now that we're getting from thames
valley police they're saying that they
responded to a security breach in the
grounds of windsor castle this morning
it happened at around 8 30.
they have taken into custody a 19 year
old man from southampton who was
arrested shortly after this security
breach
thames valley police superintendent
rebecca mears says an investigation is
now ongoing following this incident and
we are working with colleagues from the
metropolitan police the man has been
arrested on suspicion of breach or
trespass of a protected site and
possession of an offensive weapon he
remains in custody at this time she goes
on to say we can confirm security
processes were triggered within moments
of the man entering the grounds and he
did not enter any buildings members of
the royal family have been informed
about the incident we do not believe
there is a wider danger to the public so
that's thames valley police releasing
details of a security breach at the
grounds of windsor castle this morning
at around 8 30 a.m as i said a 19 year
old man from south hampton is now in
custody
you